Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so this is gonig
to be a video All about the different colors
of flash lightning.
A lot of you are requesting a video asking
about the differences between the movie flash
in the TV show flash so I'll explain everybody
from Barry Allen to Wally West to zoom to
the black flash.
there's a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts there's
a whole bunch other stuff is dropping today
to so there couple different colors of flash
lightning there shades of yellow moving into
red to blue and then the white lightning,
of savitar.
It's all meant to sleeve they're connected
to the speed force how full they are with
speed force, so the more powerful you get
the closer your lightning gets to white.
So one the color of your lightning is a function
of your connection to the speed force and
your speed, but two is also a really simple
way for non-comic book people to understand
who's fighting who on screen legates.
Somebody just walked in off the street and
they saw savitar and Barry start fighting
they would know the berries lightning is yellow
he wears a red suit savitar looks silver he
has white lightning when the running around
is blurs on screen is easier to tell them
apart largely this is taken from the comics
but there couple changes in the comics for
instance the reverse flash is lightning is
red because he uses the negative speed force.
He is a slightly different connection to it
than Barry has, but he's almost as fast is
Barry TV show reverse flash has read lightning
because he's faster than Barry.
So the TV shows, just a little bit different.
It like Jesse quick for instance they say
that she's almost as fast is Barry.
So her lightning is almost the same color
during the flashpoint episodes we saw the
rival he has a red version of the lightning
he's just a little bit faster than that version
of Wally West the new philosopher's stone
Wally West has more yellow lightning he's
not quite as fast as flashpoint Wally West
yet, just because he hadn't been the flash
for as long a period of time and that's another
thing to will have to come back around to
will savitar be able to control him or will
he do something crazy because he got his powers
via the philosopher's stone, but during season
two we met zoom who had blue lightning because
he was so much faster than Barry.
So was much closer to white savitar is the
fastest speedster that Barry as ever gone
up against.
So he has the white lightning you see from
Ginger Wally West in the comics was the fastest
version of the flash so largely they kept
that color scheme in tact but like I said,
the second reason for doing it no one denoting
speed to just denoting who is fighting who
on the pager on the screen.
So that's one of the reasons why.
When Barry was using the tacky on device during
season two to get faster at a much faster
rate is lightning didn't change colors that
much just because they want you to still know
that it was Barry on screen.
But in reality his lightning should have change
color become a more blue shade and accredited
just a little bit the movie flash that.
A lot of you are asking about why is his lightning
blue that's largely a Zack Snyder choice,
but he did explain that he wanted this version
of Barry Allen to have a much closer connection
to the speed force, so we haven't met the
other speedsters of the DCEU yet we largely
won't see the reverse flash to the flash movie
drops in a couple years.
So will know little bit better than but just
expect the same thing.
The reverse flash of the movies have a slightly
different shade of color than Barry Allen
he'll have the blue lightning reverse flash
in the movies will probably have the red lightning
just remember that the movies are different
from the TV shows in the way they use colors
like that there is some parity but they're
meant to be their own thing, so Zack Snyder
made that choice not so much based on what
the TV show is doing, so the color schemes
of the movies will be a little bit different
than the color scheme of the TV show but it
all flows from the comics back in the classic
comics it was even more confusing all the
good speedsters had the exact same color of
lightning.
So they just try to change that with the more
modern stuff that they do and that influences
the TV shows it is want people to have their
own identity.
So Wally West like the young kid flash Wally
West in the comics as a redder version of
the lightning Barry Allen's.
It still kind of yellow even though he's faster
it can be a little confusing but just remember
when you're comparing lightning colors and
top speeds of TV show characters only compare
them against the stuff that the TV show has
explain don't think too much about what happened
in the comics and don't think too much about
what happened in the movies I think a lot
of people like try to take it all into account
and he gets a little confusing they do that
even in the marvel universe with the color
of the infinity stones the different colors
in the movies and they are in the comics and
is very confusing.
So just remember the TV show the movies the
comics there all just a little bit different
but just to explain the color change for the
black flash and.
A lot of people were wondering because they
change the emblem color that's mostly just
to make him look different than he did at
the end of last season with zoom to make him
look more like an animal like he's walking
around like a velociraptor looking for the
reverse flash of his lightning is red by the
TV shows logic that means that he's just as
fast as the reverse flash meaning that he's
that big of a threat like the reverse flash
couldn't easily outrun him which is why he's
so afraid but here's the thing, though the
TV show actually change the black flash is
and zooms emblem even three times within that
final fight that Barry had at the end of season
two so that I think which is a coloring error
in post production, so sometimes the TV show
can be a little inconsistent.
So try not to read too much into that.
So hopefully that explains lightning colors
just a little bit I'm hoping for a couple
other different colors of the spectrum as
we get more speedsters in future seasons.
Maybe we can do a version of the war of light
with different speedsters going to war with
each other, but that's all way down the road.
There's a new episode posting later tonight.
There's an iron fist trailer the just drops
I'll be doing the iron fist trailer video
next my flash episode will post later tonight
the be a new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on in that to, so get hype it's going
to be awesome while you wait for that.
Here to rewatch all the Super Bowl trailers
and you can click here to learn all about
the guardians and infinity war.
Thank you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you the next video!